there is an island prison home to the
most infamous villains and have ever
lived Cruella De Vil Jafar the Evil
Queen and Maleficent each one as a child
that has never left their side until now
you're gonna be crowned king next month
I've chosen my first official
proclamation the children of the Isle of
the Lost should be given a chance to
live here in auradon you four have been
chosen to go to a different school our
John Peck what I don't do uniforms
prissy pink princesses they allow dogs
we're not gonna see me start to
encourage this summer how the next
generation of villains arrives
son of Jafar hurry done it's called
stealing it's like buying whatever I
want if it's free daughter of evil queen
does everybody at home is pretty easy I
like to think I'm Affairs to the long
beauty is pain Carlos son of Cruella de
Vil
the thing is a killer this is a vicious
rabid packing anime who told you that my
mother and now daughter of Maleficent
they're at their best when doing their
worst beware forswear undo Jane's hair
there's a lot more where that came from
oh that one domination do you think your
parents are gonna different they will be
out of us for a journalist really no I
think we are definitely goners Disney's
descendants
the Disney Channel movie event of the
year on Disney Channel you didn't know
Disney Villains have kids - and sure it
may be called Sleeping Beauty but we
know it's all about Maleficent